[Music]
Hello, welcome to Chat in the Arena, the
weekly podcast where we recommend and exchange
content that we listen to,
always bringing product insights to the
discussion. I'm Artur, and I need to tell
you that I'm going to be a
father. The secret we've been keeping for
the last two episodes, right? Congratulations, my
friend! May you be very happy and may
everything good come with health and happiness. And after this
news, I'm... there's nothing to
say but celebrate! And in
today's program, which is edition number 40,
right? Or, "Round is Round," we're going to
talk about the announcements from the
WWDC and the Apple conference. That's right. But
before we talk about that, there's
always a jab, right? Including, as
always, the jab. It will be
contextualized because there will be an
AI course for PMs that will be online and
live with me and Efren on
July 20th. And that's a topic we
'll talk about shortly: Apple
Intelligence, exactly. And besides that, there's the
critical analytical thinking course
with Dudu and me on June 29th, which will be
online and live.  July 6th will be an
in-person event here in São Paulo. The link is
in the description with that
awesome discount. Let's go! PR paa So let's go
[Music] then on
Monday there was another edition of
WWDC, which is Worldwide
Dev, and we're going to talk about the main
announcements, but I'll give you a heads-up: the
conference lasts several days, right? We
'll talk about the main KDE announcements
on the opening day, but I'll give you a heads-up
that there are many Q&A sessions and lots of
things, lots of tips and everything else on the
Apple website itself. Just go to
developer.apple.com
wwdc24 and you'll be able to see all the
sessions they do there. There's a lot of
cool content. So I recommend it for
anyone who works with product, not just developers,
although it's a conference for
developers, I highly recommend it
because there are many things there and many
examples of how to use the technologies
and everything else. I was going to say that, I think the
coolest thing is the various... Since there are
many new things that they usually
introduce, they bring best practices,
examples, so it's a good source of
inspiration, right? Like, both for apps
you work on that can take advantage
of this.  Regarding general references, Apple
is a benchmark for user experience design,
so it's always good to have this type of
content available. And an
interesting fact here: just on YouTube, we
're recording on Monday, the day
the conference took place, it already has over
5 million
views easily, right? It's good to be Apple, isn't it?
But what are we going to
start with? Oh, there's nothing else but... but of
course Apple was going to find
a way, right? They were going to find a way
to use the same
acronym, right? Because Apple Intelligence is... right?
Exactly, exactly, they can't... they ca
n't... but let's go. I think
doing an overview here, they announced
things for some topics, things for
writing, right? Things for images, and there were
also things for Siri. And I think the
interesting thing is that they gave it
this Apple Intelligence branding, and
within that, it's not just generative, right?
There are things that are generative, there are
things that are more traditional machine learning,
so they put... and at
other times, note, they also
brought machine learning applications
outside of this Apple
Intelligence branding, but...  Where are the
most generative things, in fact, that
we've been seeing in recent months, which
we've been talking about a lot here on the
Total program, and another thing,
in this
WC, Apple killed several more apps, right?
Who kills more apps, OpenAir, when they
update GPT chat or Apple? Well, it's
a good competition, now they
complement each other, right? Actually,
Apple uses OpenAir as a weapon to kill
applications, but let's start with
the Writing Tools. I think the
first thing they
did, the thing they announced, was to
rewrite sentences and
texts in a more friendly,
more professional, or more concise way. You can
put TL;DR there, you can also
make a summary, all of that helps with
responses, like the quick reply
that they also announced. I think
all the classic examples of using
GPT chat for text, they went there and
applied it within the environments, right? And
within the applications, both native and
non-native, right? So there's the one in
Notes and Mail, which I think were the
municipal examples they gave, but in
principle it works in OS.  The whole thing, right? And
I think that's the main point of
what Apple said, and I think we
mentioned this in one of the
programs here, that Apple wasn't going to
bring this as a standalone product,
right? An Apple GPT chat, they were going to bring it
integrated into OS, which is where the great
value lies, right? And if I remember correctly,
we talked about it privately during the
program, it's also about
bringing tools to people's daily lives, to the
average citizen, right?
So you bring technology as a
tool and not as an end in itself, let's say. That's it.
And with that, also,
like, various things in the image area,
right? You can add things
to something you're writing,
so add an image to a text and
everything else, even the Image Playground where
you can add images,
remove things from photos,
which Google already did with Google Photos, right?
Exactly, but now too,
and then there's another series of apps that
Apple is now doing this too,
in Google Photos, I don't know about today, but
at least when I started using it, it
was exclusive to those who subscribed to
Google One, right? It's like, man.  Apple's technology is
free for you if you
have an iPhone, so it's kind of
democratizing and spreading technology again, right? It
also has the
generative aspect, which is the
ability to create Memories, which are little
videos with your photos, and you
can write, "Oh, I want a video with such and such,"
and it creates it based on
your photos. You can also ask Siri, right?
Yes, you can ask Siri. There's also g emoji,
which is where you can make your
own emoji based on
existing emojis, and memoverse, memoverse. I
found that interesting. And there were also
things related to Siri, right?
Before getting into Siri, let me just talk
about images because I think there's
something interesting I read in a text—
I'll leave the link here
for everyone—about
Apple's take on images, and the text I
mentioned asked, "What is the
current capacity of
image generation tools?" and made
a prediction of what Apple
could bring, and the guy was
exactly precise about it.  Apple won't
let you create realistic images;
it will specify that's exactly what
it did: illustrations, animations, sketches. So
it gives these three styles. And that's very much what
this text talks about, right? With
this, you curb several problems, for
example, deepfakes. So you can,
on a device that's in the hands of many
people, address the fear of
how this
could increase the
problem of deepfakes and things like that on a popular device.
Apple said, "Look, this
is for Ji, it's very good for doing
this. I'll give you this constraint
so you can do just this, you know?"
So it's a constraint on one
hand, but it makes sense on the other. You know, yes, yes. Well,
going to Siri, I think it's very much
in line with what GPT announced a
few weeks ago. It's the
most natural conversation, the memory part, right?
You can ask and then
ask something else, and it
will pick up the previous context, the
personal context of your life. So they even give the
example of, "What time is
my mother's flight?" or "What did I arrange with her?"
Dinner. And then it grabs from your IM
Messages and your email too, what time
is the flight, what you had
arranged, and everything else. And for me, the
newest thing was the ability to
type, you know,
you can say "Type to Siri" instead
of just talking to her, right? It's totally true. And also, just
to be clear, it will
use GPT 4, right? It even asks for
permission there, the "for" key, when it needs to
click, and to give a better result,
right? And I think it's good, if you look at
the social media of the Open team
saying "Ah, a pleasure,
Partner with Apple" and so on for these
releases, then in fact, the thing that
was a rumor until then,
that Apple would use Open as a
partner for things, is true,
in fact they are using it, and we gave it here
firsthand, it wasn't just a rumor
spread, right? Artur, you who are a
guy who has been in the iOS world for a long
time, how much do you use Siri today and how
much do you think you will use it with
these new things? Well, I'll say that
I use it very little, I use it for
very simple things.  The timer is very, very little, the
alarm is very little, but I think I'll
use it a bit more, man, because I already
use GPT a lot. So now, with the
personal context, and since I have, literally,
the entire
Apple ecosystem, from the watch to the iPad to the
computer to the iPhone, I think
I'll use it much more now, you know? I do
n't know, but we'll see. I think that's
the cool thing, it's integrated into the
operating system, right? So we didn't talk about it
here, but there's the whole Actions part,
which is being able to ask Siri to
do actions. Oh, so create a to-do list
for me in my to-do list to do this or that
tomorrow. So there will be both
first-party Apple apps
and third-party apps, obviously
needing integration. We didn't
talk about it either, but it's Apple
Intelligence; it will be across devices, right?
So it's iPhone, iPad, and Mac. So it will
exist in all of them, and I think
in theory it's very cool. Like,
you ask Siri to do things, and she,
within the OS, can understand and be an
assistant. In practice, I really want to see
this implemented by third parties
because I think it will have a lot of value
when you...  It integrates with apps and such, and
I want to see because I think there's a
lot of technical complexity. They talk
about semantic search and all that, so I'm
imagining, man, several apps having to
add a semantic layer that
they sometimes didn't have to allow
the system to search for information in a
structured way and serve it. So,
I want to see if it won't just be very,
very pretty in Apple apps and
not so functional in third-party apps.
At the same time, I don't know how many
Apple users use third-party apps,
or if they're stuck in that little world of
pure apps. Like, I know a lot of
users who are Apple users, like you, but do
the average user use
iMessage, right? So I'm
imagining, man, if it's really awesome,
just in Notes, Camera, Photos, Apple Music, and
so on, it will be enough for a good
portion of users. I imagine. Well, we'll
see. And I think last but not
least, they talked
a lot about privacy, right? I think that's the
main thing there. So, at an
architectural level, a good part of the processing
will be done on the device. Which means
very likely that they are
using small language models. So they
are using  Okay,
so they're using smaller servers to do this processing, and
they're going to use Apple's own
servers, which they call private
cloud computing, where there's no
information storage. It
processes the data and returns it when needed. So I
think for the
privacy-conscious crowd, that's good news. And
I think everyone was saying that
Apple would pay a lot of attention to
privacy, and if you look at
the privacy features of iOS 18, it makes a
lot of sense that they were announced together.
Yes, and I forgot, we talked about it at the
opening, but I forgot the
coolest thing I found at this
conference was the opening
because it was the guys
skydiving, Craig, the guys
skydiving, Cra Federigo, man, Cra, no way,
he... But I was happy and
sad at the same time, because it was cool to
see a lot of people skydiving,
but sad to know that they
weren't using my skydiving app,
right? Well, now there's no chance, it would have been
perfect timing, right? Anyway, let's move on to the
next things, let
's go, Vision, Apple launched it in
February.  I was even looking here, it was
in February that we even did an
episode about this, and I don't even remember
the Apple Vision anymore. Man, I think there are
some interesting points here,
not about the device itself. The first one for me
is the Vision OS 2.0, so they made a
leap in OS development and it came out in
months, which isn't normal. Like,
Apple's iOS is one update per year, basically,
and it seemed like very little
to be a version jump. Like, for
me, it could have been 1.5 or 1.3, you know? It
seemed like very little. Because in the
end, there were some things
for photos,
more things related to the Spatial Forums,
but nothing really
different. To talk about
the new gestures, there's this, right? There's
this new gesture to see both the
battery and to go back to the home screen
and everything else. It may seem simple, but the
part I liked about it is that I wish
this was for the Apple Watch too.
We'll talk about the Watch OS later,
they brought more things too, but I
wish other gestures were also like that
for the Apple Watch, and it goes along the lines of
what we talked about there.  When it was launched,
right? Last year at the event about...
Will they put new
gestures on the Apple Watch? And since it
's on the Apple Vision... Wow, it might
be on the Apple Watch soon too,
right? What caught
my attention the most was the possibility of using
the Photos app on FaceTime with
another person who has the Vision Pro, both of
you looking at the same
things, photos, which I think is
a step towards having a
complete shared experience, which
I think is a path Apple is taking.
And for those who have Macs, it's probably
100% based on the Vision Pro. You
have a larger display and resolution in the
connection with the display, and I think that
seems like one of the coolest uses.
And I think it's super cool now that it has
widescreen, you can make it widescreen.
And along those lines, they also launched
OS Mods for use on airplanes or trains,
which is a real use case.
And I think the last thing,
for me, is that they're
teasing that this product will move
more towards a pro line.  The fact is, it's
less about consumer use because there was a part
there focused on professional workflows and things like that, like
having Canon lenses now
to capture Special Video. So it's not
just on the iPhone anymore that you
can edit Special Video in Final
Cut, you can view it on Vimeo,
which is a video service widely used
by video professionals, and so on.
They created a whole enterprise API part,
uh, Black Magic Design from Vint Resolve.
So, various applications and even
hardware services from hardware companies are
having integrations or doing
things with the Vision Pro. So, for
me, this is also a move in the
direction of positioning the Vision
Pro more as a device for professionals. In fact,
right? And another thing you noted
here, but I'll say, man, it's bizarre, right? It's been
several months since this device was
launched and there are only 2,000 specific apps,
right? They say more than 1.5 million
apps. I even thought that was a lot. I noted it
here on my list because I said 2,000
specific ones, I thought that was a lot, man, I thought it was quite a lot.
And then
another strategy, another small detail,
but it's very important to consider the strategy
they...  They're going to launch in new countries, right?
They announced it, and there's a small
phrase that says, "Oh, we're going to launch in
some other countries, starting
with China." By the way, in the last few
quarters, when Apple released its
results, one of the biggest impacts of the
results not being good was
due to sales and the problems that
were happening in China. But in the
last month, if I'm not mistaken,
the numbers started to grow again. In the
last results announcement, they
made a price cut in China, and they
started to grow again. Exactly. And then they
did a super promotion there, which
is something Apple doesn't usually
do, but they did, increasing their market share there and
consequently improving the results.
And then, logically, to make up for it, they're going to
launch the Vision Pro there too, right? It's one
of the biggest markets in the world, right?
Anyway, if there's one place
that could perhaps increase
sales, it's there, right? And just to
note, Brazil isn't on the list of
countries where the Vision Pro will be
officially launched, right? What about iOS, the
darling, man? iOS, I felt like
now I'm going to use Android, that's it for
me. The summary of the iOS presentation is
welcome to Android.  I don't know, 10, 11, I don't know,
from Android, years ago, it's at 15, I think.
So, exactly, well, in short, you can
put your icon wherever you want on the
screen now. Oh, yes, just kidding here, but there was
a cool little thing that I think,
I think for the iOS user, who was
all crippled, it's cool,
isn't it? It doesn't matter, for those who don't use iOS, I see it and say, "Let's go, now you can paint all the Zaps the same color." Now it's the Zap theme that's on Google Play, they put that in the system, and there's... But they
also redesigned the
photos app, right? I think that's cool, it turned out
interesting. And another
thing I personally use a lot
is the control center. And then they
released the things that, back then,
they put the shortcuts and everything else. There
was a lot of doubt, like, "
Why not let the developer
create the shortcuts there too to make it
easier?" It's a simple thing, and it probably
already exists on
Android, but I found it practical, and what I
found even better was...  Aspect: Two
things. One, you'll be able to use the Action
button to do what
we talked about last year in the
episode. When will they
release this? Will it take a long
time? But no, I think they were
quick. You could do it, like, work
around via shortcut, right? Yeah, but I think
they were quick. It's historically
Apple that they were quick
to release this to developers.
For me, it's the most
interesting thing about the Control Center. So,
just to give some context
for those who use iOS, when you
drag the screen down and
your screen appears, you could
put, right? Flashlight, Notes. You could put them there, but you
couldn't move them.
You could move them, yes, you could
select which ones you wanted to add
there, but they were all related to
taking these Apple things, right? Now, if
your app has it—and I'm already on
iOS 18—and I'll tell you that there are already some
apps that... Where are they already? Let me see if there
are any apps here on
iOS testing... Real Time here, I
installed it, but I haven't started exploring it
yet...  Artur, you're looking for something, right?
None of my apps have it yet, it's here, but there are
many more things now. You can
have control center pages, right? So,
a
traditional page, a page for
media control, a page for
controlling your home, which is the example
Craig gives, and so on. So,
I think it's improved the lives of
iOS users; it's not something absolutely new, which is why what
I found cool is the
Action Button, in fact, you can use it...
Action button to trigger things.
Because, in fact, improving life there doesn't
require shortcuts for business and
such, but I think it was something that had already been
resolved for some time, and Apple
just took a while to do it. Is there anything else
interesting? Oh, there's TT Cash,
right? You can tap your phone and make
a transfer through Apple Wallet,
which I think is more of a
US thing than Brazil. Brazil has
Pix, right? I was even seeing
American people saying, "Hey, you can
do this, and I did it once with
one phone next to another, you know?" So, yeah,
but in this phone-to-phone thing,
I've been using AirDrop a lot,
doing it by tapping the device against the other, you
know, instead of just the "send" option appearing,
because, I don't know, why?
Because many times it takes a while for the "send" option to
appear. Oh, okay, because it's faster to
do it, it's easier, I just go there
and bam! Remembering the late Bump?
Remember Bump? Google
bought Bump and killed it later, but that was it,
you could send photos, send some
things, you just tapped the device against the
other. Of course.  The two people had to
have the B, but it's... man, damn, it's been a long
time, but anyway, so they
released that there and released some
things for games too, right? There's going to be a
game mode there, and there's a game mode now, which
was already on Android. I don't know if it's on Android,
Samsung doesn't have it, I
think it's on Android because it's in the
mail app, now it has
Gmail categories. Man, I'm kidding here, but it's
because I look at these
iOS improvements and I miss them, and I already
said this in another podcast where
we talk about ads from that time. I
miss when the iOS ads
were really something that would
actually make people look at the
interfaces and interactions
of the mobile operating system in a different way, you
know? I think it's Para
running after it and doing it their way,
like, "Do it the way it works
on iOS," and that's it, but new, new, cool,
PR, damn. Well, I think that's it.
Later I'll send some updates
here about something I've already tested, and
what's next? WatchOS, which
I've already downloaded, and I haven't even...  I pressed
play even though I want to do the tour that
he just updated and wants to do the tour,
so I'm going to record the tour here and
then I'll put it on
PR Arena's Instagram, it'll be there. But
man, I personally really liked the
watch updates and I'll tell you
why: I'm a pseudo-athlete, right? You're
more of an athlete than a lot of people, and
last year I was in the top 12% of Strava's
athletes. But anyway,
as I said, I use the
Apple ecosystem, so I have the Apple Watch
and I really care about this stuff, I
keep track of things like sleep,
how the training is going, and everything else. And
today I have an app that I use to
help me with that, which is Trainingpix, and
in the last Apple update it was very
good because it managed to connect with the
Apple Watch features, which
wasn't possible before. So,
if you had a trainer, they
literally controlled the workout. You
had to go there and adjust it manually on the Apple Watch,
now you don't need to
do that anymore. But now they've done
some other things too.  They might
kind of kill Training Picks, which is the
app I use and was even the
app of the week.
Some people I know, I talked to
Henrique and Fábio,
said that Garmin already has some
things they've launched here, Garmin and
others, but
one more thing, exactly, but how do I use this?
For me it was great, they launched
Training Load, which is kind of for
you to calculate how your metrics are, if
you're too far above or too far below, to
calculate your route, avoid problems
of exhaustion, things like that, and to have more
insights about your workouts, also to be able to
say, "Oh, I
felt very tired in today's workout," and then you kind of
prepare the next ones, help
prepare the next workouts. I think
this will be well integrated with Fitness
later on too, right? Fitness, in the
last launch, already had an update
of this, right? You can send
your personal training there, so I think there
will be more things to come. They
also launched a new app, which is
Vitals, for you to see how
your daily health status is, the
most important health metrics, faster and better.
How does it work if you're
above or below, and it gives you more
input on what you can do, and so on?
So I liked that. And then the
other things they launched, like
Double Tap, which may be available for
some other actions as well. So that's what
we had talked about, right? When
will that happen? So I also think
they were quick with that. Again,
when we say quick here, we mean
quick based on how Apple launches
things – Apple speed, right?
Standard speed, exactly. And another thing
that's simple, but the use case
they showed has already won, which is
Live Activity on the Apple Watch
for those who use iOS, iPhones, and everything else.
Live Activity
basically means you don't need to have the
app open for it to show you
something, like, "Is Uber arriving?" It
tells you how many minutes are left and
shows the license plate. And even though
that's cool, you still needed to get your
phone to look at the license plate. Now,
you'll look directly on the device. iFood
too, right? When it was one of the first
cases here in Brazil, you can find out the
status of your order.  Okay, so it's
on the right track again, something
simple but that will once again eliminate
my need to actually
pick up my phone to see something that
I can see on the watch. I think that's it,
watchOS. There it is, I
have few opinions on this one, I think it's
the only product from that time. I've never been a
user, so the iPad
OS, I'm a user, what
we had... The highlight of the iPad OS is
the calculator app, right? Now there's a
calculator on the
iPad, right? No, but it's cool, man,
doing calculations there, for the
students, for those who are in
school, if you have an iPad you already have your
teacher there in real time. And I think it's again about
bringing to
the masses things that already exist in
other places, so like, you
could do this in the APT chat, for
example, you know, take a picture there, but
you have your Apple Pencil
there, you could do this in an
Alpha app, which is for a
much more advanced user, but no, now
you open the calculator app, you do
your calculation there, and not only in the
calculator app, you can integrate it
directly into Notes.  You can also do it in Notes,
and another thing I found, which I thought was
really cool, is SmartScript.
For example,
when you're typing on the
keyboard, it gives you the word
to correct, but when you're
actually writing,
it didn't do that before, and now it does. And
when it corrects, it corrects
your spelling, you know? That's really cool. That's
a use of machine
learning, like, the text
written there, right? Apple thinks it's an
image, so what it's doing is
probably taking that
image, transforming it into text, then
transforming it back into an image
and applying a specific style, right?
So, super cool! And
other things they
released too. You can customize the
Tab bar to add items
related to it, and remote control
too. That's cool because you can
control your grandma's iPad, TeamViewer, or
TeamViewer for iPad, right? I think it's
good. Exactly that use case
you mentioned, man.  Sometimes I go through this
with my dad or
mom, like, "Oh, you need some
help with your phone or computer,"
and a really good remote control, you know?
For example, you can point
at the person and say, "Click here," you know? It
helps teach them. So I think that's
pretty cool. I think the iPad OS continues to have
the same problem that people have been
talking about, especially with the iPad Pro.
I think it's kind of detached from Apple's product lines, you know?
Like, the iPad isn't a Mac, it does
n't need to be. It's very difficult
to find a use for the iPad Pro, you know? So,
when they
started talking about the iPad OS, one thing
I found interesting was that they did
n't... because the iPad OS now has
complementary devices like the new Apple
Pencil, the Magic Keyboard, I don't know what... I
kept wondering, is this
already a discussion that's been going on for a long
time, that at some point there will be
this merge of the iPad with the Mac? And so far...
and now, taking advantage of this, let's get into the...
I have
many opinions about... Oh my God,
Mac... Wow, man, you know what
happened with the Mac, this Mac update.
Someone at Apple turned around and said, "Hey,
let's see what Windows does and
copy it." That's what they did, man. They took advantage of that. You
're a guy, not me. I said that. I use a
Mac every day, and I say without any risk that
Windows is a far superior operating system
to macOS, man, far superior
in many things. And I think the
Mac has now brought things that
work really well on Windows, and damn, it's
going to work on mine now. For me, the
first and best thing, man, is
window management. Damn, man,
you can do
decent window management on the OS without needing a
magnet from that other app I use (I do
n't remember how it works either). But damn, man,
it's infuriating managing windows
on the Mac, man. I confess I'm
going to use that a lot, man, because I'm already
setting up my desktop like that, you know, and
now even more so. Anyway, talking about
updates, they released the new OS,
the new Mac OS, which will be called [something unclear]. But
for me, the killer feature
is iPhone mirroring. Man, I
was shocked that it didn't exist on the Mac. It
existed for developers,
so I was shocked that it didn't exist
for people, like, "Oh, that again?" And
now they...  There's something about Windows H,
I don't know if it's the same across
all brands. But between Windows and
Samsung, it's been around for years, like,
linking your phone to your phone.
So, that's it, right? Now you
won't need to... you can look at your
Instagram, your things on the screen,
minimize it, and you can do it on your desktop, on your Mac
if you have one,
and other things, right?
You'll also have
iOS notifications there, and another thing, right? You won't just
mirror your iPhone, you can
literally use the apps. Something it
does, for example, was
in the video, which I've never tested on
Windows to see if it's possible, for
example, is dragging an app from the Mac
to the iPhone screen, for example, text, I don't know,
an image, something like that.
I've never tested that to see if it's possible
to do on Windows.
For example, I use Canva a lot
to edit things, for
protection, and so on. I
always do it on the desktop, send it via
AirDrop to the phone, and now I'll
do it directly in the Canva app
on the phone, but on the computer.  To take
screenshots, send things, etc., I think it'll be
cool, it'll be very
practical, man, for product testing,
apps, sometimes you're testing the app
you work on and stuff, and you have to
keep your phone there, like in your hand, to
do it. Sometimes the phone is charging somewhere
else, and so on. Man, screen sharing is
very practical for that. If you do it on the
computer with the phone screen, right?
So you do everything from there, and it's good,
especially when you have to
share a screenshot in a meeting. Sometimes you
want to show a screenshot of what you're
doing on your phone, and you can
share it. Saying all this on
Windows, right? I don't know how it will
work on Mac, but it works that way on Windows. Damn, it's
also cool.
They also launched
Passwords, right? The password app, and it's going to
kill OnePassword and several
others. They said it will
work on Windows, I don't remember if
they said it will work on
Android, right? For me, I think the
main thing about OnePassword is that it
works on all platforms, right?
So it's like Dropbox, like you
're not stuck with one thing at a time, and I...  I
even saw people on Twitter talking about
security issues related to this,
like a SIM swap attack, which is a
problem for other things, even
taking control of your Sim, and how it
could make you lose access to your
passwords too. So I think it's something to
keep an eye on. Uh-huh. And that's it, there was
also the partnership with Ubisoft,
right? Games on Mac? No way, man, and
you, you gamer, you nerd, Apple hater, you wouldn't think so. If it were
any other company saying, "
Oh, now we'll have
gaming stuff here," you'd think it was cool. Now,
man, I would legitimately like to
see Apple becoming a
platform that's an option for those who
want to play games, because especially, man,
notebooks are expensive, right? Today, if you
buy a Mac in Brazil, it's an
expensive device, and you're giving up something
you sometimes
like, like video games, for example.
So today, you're going to buy
a notebook, you're going to look at
a Mac or a good gaming notebook,
man, you're literally saying, "Do I
want to play games?" or "Do I not want to play games?" because...
Even though Apple does
n't have the entire Teca library yet, it's not
ready for that, so it would be really cool to
live in a world where, man, because the
hardware of MacBooks is incomparable, it's
so good, so damn, if they
also become feasible machines to play
Triple-A and stuff, damn, even on an
M1 chip, I had some good
experiences with games like that, but nothing
heavy, so I played a lot of
Horizon Chase, for example, because it was a
relatively light game, but
so I hope so, the
gaming industry is also in a
difficult moment, man, so it's impossible to
know when Apple is deciding to
invest in the gaming industry and when
the gaming industry is kind of in
decline, what timing is good, good for
macOS? That's it, and what's there to
conclude? Audio and home, this segment
is almost lost.
Exactly, it's the case/video segment,
exactly. Yeah,
man, but I thought it was cool that they
answered by nodding their heads, but it's
funny, it's already strange that people talk like that
nowadays, it's very common to see
people there with headphones talking, etc., but
now they're going to start nodding their heads.  "
Moving to music, you know,
headbanging while listening to it, and that
also goes along with the various news about
Apple's new patents regarding
AirPods, right? So it could also
be a prelude to the next
releases. I missed more
AirPod stuff with the new Apple logo; I expected
them to bring more. I think we
even commented here on the show that I would think it was
awesome when Apple did that and
stuff. I missed that when I
entered that session; I said, 'Damn, now
they're going to really rock the AirPods, whatever,' but the thing
about voice isolation, if it's
really the same as what they showed there,
because Apple is a
little different from Google in terms of that,
when they show something, when it
goes to production, it's very, very similar,
actually the opposite. So, the
voice isolation, just to give context
for those who haven't watched it, literally they
show a video of a person on the street, full
of noise and everything, and it
shows them talking to another person, and
then it cuts to that other person, and that's it.
Sorry for the long message."  There's noise here, but it's completely silent,
so wow, that's crazy. Let's
see... and they also released an API, right? So
you can also add
voice isolation, especially for
games and everything else. So I think
Google Meet, Google Meet, Zoom, that's the one you have to
use, man. But
I was really
wondering if these things will only be for the
AirPods Pro and not the Max, because
all the demos they showed were
for the Pro, but the Max, well, the Max, right? It's
the most expensive, it has more features, and it
should have these things
too. I think the Pro
certainly has a higher sales volume
than the Max, right? Very
likely. And I don't know, I really don't
remember, because the last Pro
they announced also had chips, you know,
Apple chips, I don't remember which one it was, that
helped do these things, and I don't
know if the Max had them. I think not, I
think it's something, so it could be
that, you know? Like on-
device processing too, right? So it could be that,
we'll see. And then...  So,
we talked about Cass Video here, and when we talked about
video, they mentioned Apple TV and stuff, and
they added something that's been on
Prime Video for ages, which is what it is,
they called
Insight. Basically, it lets you know what
song is playing, who the
actor is. I get so mad that all the streamers
don't have this, man, because
everyone's had the
experience of watching a movie or series,
an actor appears and they say, "Damn,
this guy is the guy who did that
in another movie," and then you go and... well, that's it. But man, something
I thought was cool, and it's
also a constant complaint of mine, movies
and series nowadays... you're watching, and
people start talking, and it's too quiet, so
you go and turn up the volume, then they
stop talking, a song starts
blasting, my friend, then comes this loud, booming song, and
you have to
rush to download it, and then... From what
I understand, they're going to
automatically improve the voice quality when the voice is
quieter,
and also show
automatic subtitles in those scenarios.  So it must
be something you can turn on and
off and stuff, man, which I thought was really cool
because this is a real problem.
There are huge articles on the internet
talking about this trend in
cinema in recent years,
and it's a real everyday problem
that you don't know, that we suffer from. And
they're going to solve it, so I
thought that was cool. I didn't understand if it's only on the
Apple TV device, or only on Apple
TV Plus, and so I was left
wondering. I think it must be on Apple TV
Plus, I don't think it has to
do with the device because it seems
more like a software thing, but I thought it was cool.
And to finish,
as I said, the opening was really
cool, man, I think it's really awesome. It's not just
Apple that does it, but everyone who does it, so a round of
applause here for those who are here, a
special round of applause for those who make
these montages of one series
talking to another, you know? It's really cool, man, I
love it, it's really awesome,
the series talks to another that has
nothing to do with it, and it seems like a
conversation, man, it's really cool. The editor of the
Boston Celtics, I don't know if you've seen the...
Boston Celtics videos on
Twitter, the Car is awesome, including the Celtics
are dominating, right? No, no, no, Luca
Don, your
comparisons, exactly. That's it, with that we
conclude the
WWDC event. Yeah, right, now that was the
point of me talking about morphine and saying that
I, you, dad, the truth, if you were
Steve Jobs, you see? Yeah, but I'm not, right, man? Look,
to win it over, I had to...  Let's talk about
something you thought was really cool about the
event, which was the
watchOS stuff. Apple Intelligence doesn't
count, right? Like, naturally it's a bit different.
But then it does count, man, I liked it. So,
if you're going to talk about something specific
from Apple Intelligence, it can't be the
whole Apple Intelligence. Okay,
so it's going to be that, it's going to be watchOS, and
the second thing is going to be things related
to images. Cool, cool.
And you, window management on the Mac,
for me, is... damn! Imagine,
imagine Cook listening to this episode
that says, "Damn, man, we spent I don't
know how many millions to do just this
presentation here, how many millions here on
Payday and stuff, and they tell me that
window management is THE thing, is THE
thing, is going to make
my life easier." If we were ever going to
get a spotlight at Apple, after
Tim Cook listens to this episode,
we'll never be again, right? But anyway,
just look at what Windows does. That's it, and with
that, we end today's program
as well. That's it, so, the
usual parish announcements, follow us there and give us
five stars on [social media platform name].  The place where you most
enjoy listening, if you don't have a star you can
give a thumbs up, whatever, the important thing
is to engage.
And share the podcast, so if you
think someone might enjoy this conversation we had
here, they need to
catch up on what happened at the Apple
event, listen to a podcast about it,
send it to that person and follow us on social
media, right? @x @ur Close with k @arena and
next week there's more, that's it, and this
episode, right, which is special here, right,
episode 40 full of news, the name of
this episode will be wwdc 2024 and one
more
thing, damn, you're creative, man!
And in the last episodes, right,
people have been posting a lot about where they're
listening from, so keep it up, we messed up
here by not saying it at the
beginning of the episode, but send it,
share this episode,
where are you listening to episode 40, the
news and one more thing, and
the poll for today's program will also be here,
vote on Spotify, which of the
things that were
presented...  You liked it the most, we
'll put the Vision S iOS nu
Apple intelligence options there, but tell us
what you were most interested in from
this Apple presentation and in the next
episode we'll reveal the result.
Exactly, that's it, thanks, thanks.